I haven't really studied it but I have
heard that it is happening and because I
haven't studied it I I'm hesitant to
comment but I would think that global
warming you know it reveal knowledge
science tells you that this is a reality
now you could say and quite frankly I'd
like the answer that Sarah Palin gave on
this look either she said it's best I
can remember he says I don't know that
the process is all made by human beings
or caused by human beings because the
cyclical nature of our atmosphere and
our world may have something to do with
this but she said that I'm sure that
human beings have made major
contributions to this global warming
effort so I think that some of the
evangelicals who took the strong opinion
that you know this had nothing to do
with humankind and you know men and
women were not involved in this are
beginning to see it a little differently
and so that might account for some of
the shift another interesting thing
watching Sarah Palin she hadn't said
much about abortion an interesting thing
to that is that many men and women I
think understand particularly
evangelicals that the choice is ours I
mean I put before you life and death you
know we pray you choose life the choice
is really yours you can't legislate this
and so a woman does have a right to
choose it's a god-given right now we
pray
I do that she would choose life but it's
really up to her and so I think that
more and more people are beginning to
understand this and they're stopping the
shouting and beginning to listen talk
and pray together and that might account
because the radical extremes on either
side not where we ought to be and I
think also this young senator from
Illinois mr. Obama has caused people to
realize that there needs to be more of a
moving to a common ground understanding
and that might be a reason that some
evangelicals are moving I think it's
good to say I had no reservations about
Barack I think that he is qualified
visionary strong absolutely is
intelligent articulate no question but I
believe he's committed to his principles
and the issues that he exposes so I had
no reservations but I'm a New Yorker and
I have a long and meaningful
relationship with the Clintons for
example I'm the president of State
University of New York in our West bird
I took over a college that was not in
good shape and we built it up it's an
excellent shape now but during the
process of rebuilding the school I
needed help and I remember picking up
the telephone once and calling Bill
Clinton and so mr. president I'd like
for you to come out and speak for our
College
so I have a big luncheon that raises
money to send young men and women
overseas to study just travel up study
abroad and he said he would come
actually I put it in the more colloquial
Wester can you help a brother out he
said I'll be right there now not only
did he come he didn't charge me anything
and I raged with Bill Clinton the
largest amount of money that the college
has ever raised since its inception you
can't you can't forget that he
established an office in Harlem Hillary
Clinton has been very supportive of our
community development activities what I
call our kind of creative protest
against deterioration and as of the
United States Senator I've been with
Bill Clinton in many settings Hillary
Clinton in many settings when they have
acknowledged our work encouraged us put
us in contact with people who can help
us how do you walk away from that
that would make me less of a person and
so when mrs. Clinton said that she was
going to run for president I said that I
would support her in the primary and I
stick by my word I talked with Senator
Obama and we had a very good
conversation I said you know senator if
I lived in Illinois we wouldn't have a
problem but I'm a New Yorker now two
more points my congressman is Charles
Rangel chair of the powerful Ways and
Means Committee and my senator is
Charles Schumer a very powerful man in
the Senate they too were supporting
Hillary Clinton and they also have
worked with us in our community
development activities in our
educational programs and so
I stuck with Hillary Clinton because
she's been a friend and I think that she
is eminently qualified she's paid her
dues she would have been a tough
candidate now when the primary was over
and she did not win and Barack Obama did
absolutely no question and I told Barack
Obama that face to face as close as you
and I are right now that I would support
him and I am supporting him vigorously
without apology and I want him to win
because I think it would be good for
America but that still does not take
away my high regard and respect for
Senator Clinton and I really hope that
her career in there are many my
colleagues
others who say that Barack Obama wins
that's it you know you would have
ascended to the presidency as an
african-american and there'll be no more
need for affirmative action and you know
the race issue is dead in America
because whites have voted in big numbers
for Barack Obama
but that's not the case Barack Obama
will be President of the United States
of America but that won't end the
conversation on race there's still a lot
of people in this country who have to
wrestle with this issue black and white
there will be racial incidents there
will be police brutality and there will
be those by the way who are just
incensed with the fact that we have
elected a black president and they will
let it be known and so I think we're
going to be involved in this
conversation unfortunately for a long
time however we would have made a big
step forward in the discussion but I
think we're still going to have to
wrestle with issues like affirmative
action
how people of African descent are being
treated in jobs and advancement and jobs
education you know it's still a niche
and Barack Obama once he's elected is
not gonna be able to solve all the
problems note that just as any person
who's elected is you've got a Congress
to work with you know you've got a court
to work with it will be a good thing but
it will not be the end of the racial
discussion it will not be Nirvana it
will not be a fantasy it will not be
shangri-la we're still going to have
some struggles in America but thank God
for the struggles and I think the the
the conversation will be even more
focused